this is one of the biggest tabloid
stories
of last week it just broke on friday i
guess it was thursday or friday
bar stool sports
dave portnoy who is this larger than
life character from bar stool sports and
his whole shtick is he's big and he's
brash and he's loud and he's irreverent
and he sleeps with a bunch of girls and
he eats a bunch of pizza and he does
whatever he wants that's his whole
character well it turns out that that
guy
sleeps with a bunch of girls and eats a
bunch of pizza and does whatever he
wants and flies a lot of conventions the
headline from a business insider hit
piece on him is quote
i was literally screaming in pain young
women say they met barstool sports
founder dave portnoy for sex and it
turned violent and humiliating
okay
the piece opens up
with
dave portnoy and some chick sexting
right so
dave
and she messages dave dave says the the
conversation quickly turned to the topic
of sex he sent her graphic videos of
other women he'd slept with according to
madison and in messages reviewed by
insider he pressed her to tell him about
her sexual fantasies
i mean actually this one's kind of
common she wrote like a rape fantasy
where i don't have any control of what's
going on you and i are going to get
along so well he responded so then he
sends her a first class ticket to his
mansion in nantucket she flies out there
and they have sex
and she's much younger than he is you
know she's what 19 or 20 20 years old
and they they have sex and he started
filming her without asking permission as
she performed a sexual act on him
she must have been shocked by this
except she couldn't have been shocked
because he sent her videos that he had
of him doing this to other women
i never said anything i was scared he
was just so mean and then
i felt like i was just a human sex doll
and uh
it was so rough
it felt like i was being raped
and then she goes on to describe the the
acts that they engaged in
do you see the problem with this this as
a hit piece as an accusation
it opened up with her saying i want to
feel like i'm being raped
and then
she flew out there and hung out with him
and then she was shocked to when it felt
like when he did the thing she asked him
to do
she he just did he just obliged
she said she wanted to do this thing he
did that with her and then she regretted
it since i was but a wee young lad i've
had some back problems okay it affects a
lot of people
and i never knew exactly how to fix it
you know you do this stretch use this
product well i've got an amazing
solution home medics they've got a whole
line of massage products from a massage
gun with built-in hot and cold
technology to a massage cushion that
lets you lie down or sit up depending on
your therapeutic needs that's the that's
my favorite one actually they've also
got a three in one foot massager with
vibrations so powerful that it loosens
the muscles in your legs and lower back
i have one complaint though about
homedics and this is a real i want to be
as transparent with you as i can be
homemedics is so good that if you bring
it into for instance your office at the
daily wire your staff members will steal
it from you this is my only complaint i
love my home medics i love the foot
massager i love the the massage cushion
except i don't have it anymore because
my freaking staff members stole it from
me it's just that good i guess i need to
get another one luckily they're not very
expensive so you can you can get more
whether you're dealing with chronic pain
or just looking to help your muscles
recover from a workout we've got good
news right now if you go to
homemedics.com knowles use promo code
knowles you will receive a free portable
phone sanitizer when you buy a hundred
dollars or more in massage products
sixty dollar value h-o-m-e-d-i-c-s
dot com slash knowles use the promo code
knowles for your free portable phone
sanitizer with a hundred dollar massager
purchase
now there's a few layers to this
i don't want to just let dave off the
hook i mean as a legal matter and
frankly even as a reputational matter in
this
decadent
world of the hookup culture and
everything that we're living in
dave portnoy did nothing wrong
right everything was consensual the
woman literally asked for it you know
you're not never supposed to say she
asked for it she literally asked him to
do this
and then
he did that and then she regretted it
but there's a deeper
there's a deeper level here that's the
libertarian level that's the level of
consent that's the level of look they
consented and whatever two people
consent whatever to adults consent to do
is totally fine
right that's the leftist level
i guess now the leftist level is if the
woman comes to regret it later then it's
a crime and you should be thrown in
prison but that's the kind of liberal do
whatever you want just everyone who has
to agree to it but there's a deeper
conservative level which is it's wrong
to do this even if the people sort of
consent
it's still wrong because there's there's
something beyond consent that there's a
moral standard that is even higher than
consent yes you need the consent but
there's something even if some woman
says degrade me humiliate me do all
these you still shouldn't do it because
it's objectively wrong to do and
i don't even really blame portnoy here
the whole culture is confused about this
we're saturated in this kind of language
of liberation and consent and the sexual
revolution so we don't even realize that
it's just still wrong to do this and
it's degrading and it's humiliating and
people don't don't even really desire it
there's a difference between what they
think they desire this woman thought she
desired this rape fantasy and what they
actually desire she hated it when she
got she's like the dog that caught the
car when she got it she hated it
because it's degrading
have a lower will and we have a higher
rational will
and
before the decadence especially the
sexual revolution we recognize that we
pursued the higher will and we
suppressed all of our
creepy pervy weird urges
but in the sexual revolution we kind of
turned it we turned it completely on its
head
very
and now it's look i i kind of feel bad
for portnoy port and i played according
to the rules of the liberal society and
now he's getting burned because the
liberal society doesn't like him
harvey milk rapes young boys it doesn't
matter because he was a leftist and he
works with their narrative and so he's
going to become a secular saint but dave
portnoy he's kind of politically
incorrect sometimes he kind of goes
against the left-wing narrative and so a
reporter is going to spend eight months
digging up whatever dirt she can find
talking to every woman he's ever slept
with and you know what the thing is
she's gonna get something she's gonna
get somewhere
and and people are gonna feel like the
rug was pulled out from under them well
you gotta recognize no matter what the
don't fall for it don't fall for the
culture of liberation and whatever
people consent to do is fine it's a trap
it's a trick it's not
real thanks for watching that vid man
i'm glad you liked that if you want all
of the cool vids and clips and episodes
full-length episodes ring that bell
subscribe here on youtube sometimes our
overlords on this platform don't like to
send the notifications so if you want to
be sure to get the full uncensored show
all the time head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]